Andre is calling hi Andre how are you
hello sir I'm good thank you doing how
can I help
so my husband and I have about fifty two
thousand dollars of debt in line of
credit and visas and what is hindering
us in paying any of that back is that we
foolishly have two brand-new vehicles so
I just want to know what my plan of
attack is I get this debt paid off don't
you what's your household income ninety
seven thousand and what are you on the
car the truck we owe thirty six thousand
one hundred and eighty seven mm-hmm it's
financed the Traverse is a lease it's a
brand new lease about six months hooker
on that car when you got it I actually
don't know what the sticker of the
Traverse was roughly fifty thousand yeah
that's what I'm thinking okay so you
have eighty six thousand dollars worth
of car dad basically yeah and you make
97 yes yeah that's an issue is what kind
of debt you said credit cards so the its
student line of credit and a visa so
three of the four line of credits and
one is a visa not sure okay well here's
um the math facts for us right the
largest things that you and I buy
price-wise that go down in value our
cars yeah cars lose sixty to seventy
percent of their value in the first four
years that you own them when you buy a
new car
it's you know it's thirty thousand bucks
it's gonna be worth ten eleven thousand
bucks in four years okay and since it's
the largest thing that is going the
wrong way mathematically it is the
biggest theft or one of the biggest
thieves of our wealth building because
it's going down a value and then add to
that if we financed it so even if you
paid cash
four cars and had no debt on them you
would not want to have too much tied up
in cars because they go down in value
now what is too much too much is a ratio
okay it's a ratio of you know your
income which is your wealth building
tool in your case ninety seven thousand
to the cars so what we have figured out
and run numbers on is if you have
vehicles paid for or not and this is
anything with an engine in it added
together cars trucks motorcycles see
dues boats lawnmowers tractors whatever
added together they all go down in value
if they all added together equal more
than half your annual income you have
too much tied up in things that are
going the wrong way for you to succeed
mathematically and wealth building is
that logical to you
absolutely okay and so that's where you
are not only if you God not only is this
debt choking you to death but you have
eighty six thousand dollars in cars and
you should have no more than about forty
five thousand dollars in cars okay so my
dad has two vehicles that are both
2013's in good conditions that he is
willing to sell us so they'll be used
vehicles they're good enough what is my
plan what do you sell them to you for he
would sell it to us for probably 15
apiece okay that's $30,000 that's a move
down really enough of a move down giving
them a given the mess that you've got
I'd put you in two or three thousand
dollar cars okay each until you get your
mess cleaned up and then if you want to
move up in car with cash that's fine but
you don't have $30,000 you know then so
you know you can't you got to stop
borrowing money to buy cars and you got
to stop buying vehicles to total more
than half your annual income and and
that's not a Dave thing that's a math
thing great and so if I were in your
shoes is how I answer questions on this
show I'm gonna use that set of material
that set of content you and I just
talked about that set of facts
that we just talked about in order to
make my decision if I'm in your shoes
and that means I'm selling both of these
cars and as soon as possible and I'm
getting two three thousand dollar cars
that I pay cash for and then I'm going
to get out of debt and then I'm gonna
build my emergency fund and then I'm
gonna pay cash to move up in cars but
that is all gonna take you three years
okay
that's what you know if you run the math
out how quick can you pay off 50 to make
a 97 if you don't have these cars great
you know a year and a half and then you
got to build up your emergency fund and
then you got to save up to move up in
cars so you're driving you're driving
Junkers for between two and three years
hoop Dee's in order to get your life
back
yeah because think about it if you
hadn't no payments at all except a house
payment
it's a completely different place your
chest yeah your chest isn't as tight
your stomach's not in your throat your
back doesn't hurt your neck isn't stiff
when you go to bed and all of those
things happen because of the amount of
debt you guys have right now this is
just not fun it's a bad place you're in
and I'm sorry but that's exactly what I
would do you're in a very radically bad
situation and so the the the
prescription the prescription or the
antidote is radical because when you
move from $86,000 in cars to $6,000 in
cars your friends or your parents are
gonna think you've lost your freakin
mind
but here's when you lost your mind when
you bought these things but it really is
a radical mess and so it's gonna require
a radical solution to the problem so now
here's what's interesting as we think
about that I was with a guy that they
goes you don't like me and I'm like who
are you how do I know I don't like you
how do you know I don't like you I don't
know remember meeting you he said well
I'm a new car dealer I'm not mad at new
car dealers I bought two new cars last
year I don't tell you not to buy a new
car after you've got a net worth of a
million dollars or more you can buy a
new car if you want but pay cash for it
and it needs to be the total of all your
vehicle
equals less than half your annual income
and so I mean just think that through
okay and so or you know it needs to be a
small percentage of your net worth okay
I've got a friend of mine that um just
bought a four hundred and twenty five
thousand dollar car now I'm from Antioch
Tennessee that blows my freaking mind I
can't get my head around that okay but
he's worth a billion dollars he's a
billionaire okay so let me give you the
ratios a billionaire buying a four
hundred and twenty five thousand dollar
car is like a millionaire buying a four
hundred and twenty five dollar car so in
other words he could he could buy one a
week and it probably wouldn't affect him
mathematically now I understand
emotionally and some of you think you
have to be poor spiritually and it's
hard for most of us to get our head
around a car like that I I can
sympathize with that I'm that guy too
but when I understand that's the ratios
I remember a few years ago there's a big
stink Tiger Woods bought a house that
was like I don't know there's like 170
million dollars or something that year
he made a billion dollar income okay and
when you back out the numbers it's like
you know somebody making a hundred
thousand dollars buying a seventeen
thousand dollar house something it's
it's it's so you
it's about ratios because it is the room
left for you to wiggle is the room left
for you to be generous is there room
left for you to be in by the way my
friend who bought the four hundred and
twenty five thousand dollar car this is
worth a billion dollars gives away
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
hundreds of millions his income is
ridiculous and so you know and yet he'll
get criticized for having this car but
for him it's like most of us buying a
biscuit you know it doesn't show up
so that's what you want you want your
cars I mean if you want a zero-turn John
Deere tractor to mow your grass width
that's $12,000 I'm ok with that as long
as you don't have $12,000 to your name
and a hundred percent of your net worth
is in a zero turn tractor which would
make you stupid okay but if you've got
two million dollars and you want a nice
John Deere tractor to drive around your
yard with get you one but pay cash for
it and make sure it's a small percentage
of your world that's how you look at
this stuff it keeps you spiritually on
balance financially on balance and
generously on balance